hi everyone thanks for joining us today
to see a quick demo of my great for
anthos this demo shows how a multi-tier
application running on vmware on-prem
can be migrated and run on gke
containers it also shows how to update
an image using the created docker file
and how to deploy the updated image as
part of day 2 operations so just a
little bit of an orientation the demo
covers an application server and a
database server running on VMware
on-prem we're going to migrate them to a
gke cluster where the relevant services
like load balancer and the database
application were moved as well will
extract the image apply to the cluster
and then we'll go through an image
update using cloud build and apply that
update using rolling upgrade to the
cluster
this is the VMware deployment we have on
Prem as you can see the application
server and the database server are
running two different operating systems
one SUSE a Linux and the other sent to
us and for the purpose of this demo we
already might've the suite CRM database
as a stateful set and will now migrate
the souza
web and application server first let's
look at the application running on Prem
this is an open source CRM application
it's using a lamp stack you can see here
the application running now let's switch
over to the kubernetes cluster side and
here you can see the suite CRM dashdb
container already running as a stateful
set we also have the load balancer setup
for the application and it will serve it
once the application is executed on the
cluster let's go and install the migrate
four Antho software on that cluster for
that we will use the MiG CTL setup
install command the make CTL is
available on cloud shell and the set up
install command will connect to the
cluster and apply the different solution
components you can then run Meg CTL
doctor to see that installation is
complete and in that case it will return
a check on deployment if there are any
issues it will be shown here instead of
the check on deployment next we will
configure the source from virtual
machines that are going to be migrated
and you can configure multiple sources
in this demo we will define the VMware
on Prem as a source so we'll configure
the manager address for migrate for
compute engine and the cloud extension
to which we want to connect to so that
we can use Maya for compute engine as a
transport and you can see the source as
configured next we'll create a migration
plan for this will identify the VM we
would like to migrate this is the VM we
saw on the VM side and since it is a
stateless application we will specify an
image for the intent flag and then
create the migration command to ask only
for image extraction the migration plan
is written into a Yama file
can be reviewed and customized
in the ammo file you'll see the
definitions for the different artifacts
that are going to be generated as well
as default filters for exclusions of
directories and files that are not going
to be included in the image as well as
the target image names for deploying
into GCR once these are built next we're
going to generate the artifacts
basically feeding this migration plan
into the migrant for anthos will execute
the migration and the breakdown of these
different artifacts for this we will use
the make CTL generate artifacts command
first the migration plan is validated
and then it's applied to the cluster the
migration is applied as a C R D so you
can also use the CR D as an API to
automate this migration then you'll use
the make CTL migration status to monitor
the status and progress of this
migration throughout it's different
activities
what you'll see now is that since we are
communicating with the on-prem VMware
system the VMS that are still running on
Prem will be picked into a snapshot and
from that we will start extracting the
image here we can see that the image
extraction applied into GCR with the
image name that we configured into the
migration plan so we skipped the entire
upload process to GCR
in addition in a bucket in GCS you will
find the set of crated artifacts as
dockerfile and deployment artifacts that
are usable for further deployment and
day to operations when you'd like to
update this image later to download the
artifacts you can use the mix ETL
migration get - artifacts command with
the migration name and you can see the
deployment spec that was automatically
created or the image that was
automatically built and this deployments
pack can be applied to this or any other
cluster where you would like to run
these workloads so let's go ahead and
apply the deployment so that we can see
the application running
you
now that the deployment is applied it is
inserted into the environment we pre
created just as a reminder we have a
load balancer setup and we also have an
auto scaler configured so when this
deployment goes into place the
autoscaler kicks in automatically and
sets up a minimum and maximum pods and
the monitoring on the CPU metrics
according to those conditions so you can
immediately see some of the kubernetes
capabilities in action
now let's connect to the load balancer
and you can see the application running
will just connect to this internal load
balancer and you can see the application
now running in G ke
you
now that the application is running
we're switching to talk about day 2
operations let's say that we have a
package that is a user-mode package in
the image and we would like to update it
in this case we will put the user-mode
package for update in the doctor file
that we downloaded as part of the
generate artifacts this is for example
an open SSH package then this doctor
file can be fed into cloud build with a
single g-cloud command and we get a new
built image that includes the updated
package we're using here an update for
SUSE a Linux so we're using the package
manager in zipper to update the image
we want you to see the image built we've
accelerated this process
it usually takes 12 to 13 minutes to
complete but we sped this up a bit for
the sake of this demo
you
now that the image is updated and built
if we go to the repository we can see
the updated image version and we can go
and perform a rolling update on the
actual deployment remember that we have
now a deployment with three pods running
the web front-end so we're going to
apply a live update in this live update
you will see the new version being
provisioned alongside the old version
and then the old version being
decommissioned during this process the
application is staying up
and you can see that here while this
process is going on the application is
still accessible and in a few seconds
the update process will be completed
you
and now we can see the updated image
version has been applied and we did not
have to touch any of these instances
individually
that concludes our demo of my great for
anthos today thank you so much for
taking the time to watch it and we look
forward to more demo videos in the
future